the ethiopian leader who won a nobel
prize for ending one of africa's longest
running conflicts
has for the past month been waging a war
of his own making
in early november prime minister abi
ahmed announced that he had ordered
troops
to respond to an allegedly deadly attack
on a government military base
in ethiopia's tigre province leaders
there
say the tigrayan people are being blamed
for tensions that surfaced
as abi implemented reforms and postponed
elections due to covid
can he heal his divided country or will
the fighting resume
our title today ethiopia's abi ahmed
from nobel peace laureate to man of war
[Music]
and here to answer that question our
three outstanding guests it is a great
pleasure to welcome them
starting with prince afsba wasan asarate
he descends from the family of the
ethiopian emperor
an author and analyst he also works as
an economic consultant on africa
and he says the military operation of
the ethiopian government in the tigray
region did not target the people of
tigre
but the ruthless tplf party
and it's great to have mcconan mescana
with us once again
he is head of migration and diversity at
the heinrich beau foundation
and he says the civil war in ethiopia is
just the beginning
of a long conflict
and finally we're honored to have with
us mulu solomon bezune she's ambassador
extraordinary and plenty potentially
of the federal democratic republic of
ethiopia
and she says ethiopia's current
situation is not a civil war
nor an armed conflict it's a law
enforcement operation
aimed at restoring the constitutional
order
of the country
so let me start by asking you dear madam
ambassador
there's clearly some disagreement uh
amongst
you about the scope of the fighting in
tigre province
you say it was a law enforcement
operation but the fact is ethiopian
generals
spoke of being at war the fighting did
last over three weeks
and eyewitnesses reported both artillery
duels and
also shelling of the tigre capital
michele
so that doesn't really look like law
enforcement
actually when you say it's a war or
something like that
if it is a different country or
different
equal level different people try to
fight each other with equal
standing but these are criminals who
deliberately attacked the
national the national defense forces
which was there for more than 20 years
keeping the country keeping makali
and these people not only doing this
extraordinary very devastating
crime they have been doing the same for
two years but
government was very very patient and
trying to solve
issues with with peace and
reconciliation where they rejected all
the
requests of coming to table to talk
because they don't want the country to
stay unless they lead on the top
because they lead this country for more
than 27 years
and their name was still tegra
liberation front we don't know who knows
from whom they are going to liberate to
cry
they have been leading it for 27 years
and now
what we are talking about is this is a
criminal body it's not that a great
people
the tiger people are suppressed
suffering like any other ethiopian
people
are ethiopians the issue is with this
junta this is this clique
which they want to dismantle the country
with their allies and
doing so many criminal criminal acts
including
causing killing planned financing
designing throughout the country for two
years all this was
tolerated even they denied the presence
of the
denied the presence of the federal
government they deny everything because
of when the
term is extended according to the law
because of covet which tested the world
and then they say they don't accept the
federal government they make
illegal election which is not legal and
they did all unconstitutional all this
was tolerated finally you know what they
did and did you expect any
any government to sit down and see when
the country is dismantled the country's
sovereignty is become a question and the
country will be dispersed
this is unacceptable we want to dig in a
little deeper uh
in just a moment about the background of
the
ethnic tensions in tiger province but
mcconaughey
what's your response uh to what we've
just heard would you
also say that this is a law enforcement
operation you your opening statement
referred to a long-running conflict
ahead
well taking the historical background of
the
tensions between the central government
and the region
i'm now looking rather more into the
region
and less to the leading force
integra but it was also part of the
government in ethiopia
so taking the historical aspect that
from this region
went a long-standing war the tiguay
region was fighting 17 years
against the central government which was
uh the the military
junta of mexico maryam and which toppled
and then came into the power so i'm very
much
aware but also concerned that
this tension between the federal
government and the
government of tigray would lead
to instability in the region as such
region of the grey
and also um could nurture uh
tensions which has been there for a long
time
so not only on the government basis but
also on the ethnical basis that's what
i am very much afraid of and again i do
want to talk about that in a little more
depth later but just
on that one point law enforcement
operation or military action
well i i would consider it is a military
action because uh the dimension
of the the military actions taken
it was uh more than a law enforcement
which i think
would have been more a police
operation but this was uh a more
complex and more uh
with more armaments and even the number
of
people who were participated in the
under and operation was
a massive one but cesaro let me get you
to weigh in
on this uh and also what your tell us a
little bit about what you're hearing
from friends and family
in ethiopia if as your opening statement
says this
military operation didn't target the
people
why have tens of thousands of people
fled the region
for the simple reason because they know
that
if some fighting breaks out in that part
of the world
things might happen
that would be dangerous for their lives
i think it was a precautionary
measure by most of them who fled as we
knew
there were already 20 000 people in the
sudan
in the early days of the military
operation
but basically i find it what exactly
what we call it i think is immaterial
one thing that is true is a very tragic
situation
that for so many times now that
ethiopians are fighting
ethiopians and the ethiopian blood is
being shed
but i think this is not the fault of the
central government
it is uh it's it is
it is it is the right not only the right
but it is
obliged to maintain the territorial
integrity
and the national and the national uh
sovereignty of the country and could not
allow itself to just sit there while its
troops
were being massacred in the in the front
of eritrea in the province of tigre so i
think as far as who
was responsible we don't need to
question it
at all there were many many times
many ways and many the central
government
did really take its time to want to
negotiate with them prior to what had
happened
in the northern command and
due to the hebrews of the tplf
they declined they did not wash
negotiation
with the central government before and
that is why military measures had to be
taken
we just heard prince azerate refer to
bloodshed
madam ambassador the prime minister has
said that not a single life
was lost but can we be sure of that the
fact
is that there were communications to
tigre province were cut off
there was no internet connection and uh
independent
media have not really been permitted to
cover the fighting
initially i will explain what mcconnell
mentioned with what you said
when these people start
robbing the country's biggest station
of the national defense force and they
themselves announced
that they have accused they have
acquisition of all the biggest
ammunition
and announced that they can destroy the
whole country and including adi sababad
arteria what have you and do you expect
the government to sit down while they
are having all this ammunition and
try to to destroy the country and
dismantle the country
and we want our country in peace and
obviously why the people of tigre fleet
or others flee to the country to the
neighboring country is that
they know what they have been doing long
ago and they were in the jungle
they hide in the society themselves kill
their own people and
pretend as if it was done from the other
side even last time they
manufactured ethiopian troops uniform
ertyrian troop uniform
and there are people who are wearing it
to pretend to receive the world
to that as if the government is killing
this is always they do this and the
world knows this
that the people know when they are
coming to be in the shield they want to
make a shield they are people
the people will be affected themselves
might kill them
they live that's why they know how the
in my cadres they see
they kill the civilians that's what they
are afraid about and they have to live
otherwise it's not because they are
against the government you see now
when the government is it they gave all
the ammunition they gave them
to fight they give it to the government
back nobody forces them
they are the one who give information to
the government they think they are on
people
no ethiopian people integrate have no
problem you'll see they live together in
peace
it's only the illite creating a problem
mcconan what do we know about
the fighting that was going on for the
past four weeks as i said the prime
minister says
there was no blood spilled uh do we know
that for sure apparently eyewitnesses
have have contended uh that there were
deaths
well we have a number of accusations and
counter-accusations
and as we all know in war the truth is
the first casualty
so it's very hard to verify many of
the information and we know that there
are different versions
we know that civilians has been harmed
so far
and uh we have heard that the regional
group of uh
human rights group in ethiopia tried to
verify the situation and could also find
some of the facts that probably tplf
militia may have been involved in that
and a bit but there are also casualties
from the tourist side that
the regional government accuse
the central government's militia
it shouldn't be necessarily uh
the government's uh deeds
but you know in war situations militias
take their own autonomous measures as
well you have to know that
and the second thing is of course we
have a number of uh
humanitarian crisis we have idps
internally dispersed
displaced persons around one million
within the targarye region
we have something like 44 000 refugees
who fled to sudan and unhcr
is estimating that if the
arms conflict is not going to stop
immediately that maybe up to 200 000
people may
flee to sudan so we have a clear
humanitarian crisis in this region and
we need
to immediately settle any conflict again
we will come back to that
shortly but i'd like to take a closer
look at
the role of the prime minister because
in fact only a year ago
the multi-lingual abi ahmed with his
mixed christian muslim background was
being compared to nelson mandela
barack obama seen as the bright hope of
a country
that has long been torn by ethnic
conflict so how did the nobel peace
laureate
come to be involved in military conflict
pictures from 1998 tens of thousands of
people were killed
and hundreds of thousands fled in the
territorial dispute
between ethiopia and eritrea abi ahmed
is also a soldier in this war
when he became prime minister in 2018
the political scientist embarked upon an
unprecedented course of reform
he extended his hand to eritrea for
reconciliation
and returned territories abi ahmed
liberalized the ethiopian economy
removed old officials
and met with leaders from partially
divided ethnic groups
abi ahmed celebrated by his followers
and internationally hailed as a beacon
of hope
the nobel peace prize for 2019
to ethiopian prime minister
abi ahmed ali the tide turns just one
year later
abi ahmed began a military offensive in
tigre in the northern part of the
country
the tigre an ethnic minority and an
important part of the political
elite feel that they are being ousted by
the new head of government
whose family is descended from
ethiopia's two largest ethnic groups
the amoro and the amhara will abi ahmed
continue his course of reform
it's a pretty abrupt shift at least
that's what it looks like
from outside that the prime minister has
made ambassador
this idea that the prime minister
represented the bright
hope of ethiopia and africa was it
inflated expectations on the part of
those of us
looking from outside no it was perfect
even today it's his hope of africa and
why
if unless a person leading a country
when he's
unless he keeps his country's integrity
and safety
peace and stability how can he talk of
his neighbors and what
he is still working to stabilize and
keep the peace
and make rule of law in order otherwise
if you cannot keep the peace of your own
country how can you be a peace
ambassador or peace
laureate to work on the others what the
lord
peace lord ship he received is because
he make a peace in
syria and also the neighboring countries
but especially for syria
and again today while his country is
facing this challenge
with those junta who want to rule the
country unless i rule the country let
the country be destroyed
how can he sit down and see when
ethiopia has dispersed ethiopia is
dismantled
it's impossible and it is his duty as a
government as a leader
to keep the rule of law and to keep the
peace
stability and also sovereignty of the
country
princess arete would you agree with that
assessment
or would you say that he perhaps
moved too far too fast with his reform
process
and thereby help to set in motion the
tensions that erupted
in tigre i wouldn't say that
at all he did not move too fast in some
of the things he moved too slow
there are many ethiopians who believe
that what he did today
against the tplf should have been done
two years ago
when the whole reformist movement
started
because what they have been doing in the
past two years is to
really to take care that his
reformist agenda did not take place
and they were involved with everything
that was there to destabilize
ethiopia whether it was the killing and
mass occurring
of so many people in the south part of
ethiopia
the hands were is it or whether it was
the dismantling of ethiopian statutes
in london believe you me the hand of the
tplf
was always there so i don't think it is
a matter of
having moved too far and i think also
we can only come and to to rest
if the ethiopian government will one
very soon declare the tplf a terrorist
organization
uh otherwise uh things are not going
to calm down mcconan if you would
give us a little bit of background on
these long-running ethnic tensions
in ethiopia with tigre but also
elsewhere and also why did they
explode particularly after this reform
process began
well ethiopia as how it the constitution
of ethiopia is as a multi-ethnic
country and which has been living in
different
models uh it has been living in a very
peaceful
manner as a neighboring uh ethnicity so
that the multi-ethnicity is one of its
resources actually of ethiopia
and uh whatever happened whatever
political
system was reigning in ethiopia the
people managed to live peacefully
together
but then you have also undemocratic
political systems which were using
the multi-ethnicity and the regional
tensions there are always tensions when
there are
more ethnicities which has been always
ignited by by different
local leaders and so on and governments
has been always trying either to rule
by heart as a military dictatorship of
menstrual marijuana marriage
was trying to keep you know the whole
country you know by force
and then came uh he was toppled by the
tplf
because the togai region was actually
also historically marginalized
as many other regions and then they used
this marginalization as a political
resource
to mobilize and topple the government
and then
and that was the second other issue that
the government
created a constitution which is based on
ethnic federalism
so and this is one of the sources of
conflict of course
with you know with some exit options
even to succeed if it doesn't work
within the
federal state and this was like an exit
option for tigre as well if it works
it's fine if it doesn't work
maybe and this is i think what what
happened as
abi ahmed who was actually the first
who came peacefully to power which is
you know
very positive action and then with the
reforms but then
you know he came into a situation where
you have some kind of a parallel
state within the ethiopian state there
was a tug right state
which is a kind of parallel situation
and then he had to deal with this very
complicated situation
and that is also the historical i think
dimension
we need to look when you deal with
differences with conflicts
that you cannot simply solve militarily
because of the
historical complexity ambassador prince
asarate said if anything perhaps the
prime minister should have acted sooner
to crush ethnic uh resentments in tigre
province
in fact abby wanted to govern with a new
style and when he came into office his
motto
was medema which means something like
harmony as i understand it
was he perhaps naive was the turbulence
that we are now
seeing to be expected should he have
perhaps
uh acted more with greater toughness in
the beginning
no no he's not knife madonna is showing
forgiveness and what he was trying is
it's not like revolutionary to kill and
finish those junta who would lead the
country
with abuse of human rights and big
corruption looting the country's money
he said let us live apart what they have
done wrong
let us take what they have done good and
go forward without any grudge without
any conflict
so that we keep everybody on board
anything could go in democratic election
that's why
people are against abi because he was
too patient he was too
pushing on giving forgiveness and keep
them two years and half
by trying to convince the people
regarding the federalism
it's not abby is not saying anything
that he knows that it is ethiopia as a
multinational
diverse country each and everything that
could be
managed whether we take any type of
federalism depends on the discourse of
the society each and every people
each and every region when they go
after this election what's going to do
is how the government
go to handle this thing would depend on
the discourse of the people not his
decision but the issue the fear
if the if he's against this federalism
that igra is going there
why did he allow siddha to visa attain
the federal state
he's not against federalism but we have
to choose as a society
which is good for the people but they
don't know what they need
they need unless we need ethiopia unless
we rule utopia
that shouldn't exist that's what's
happening now
princess a report that we just saw
concluded by asking what will become of
the reform
process what is your take on that do you
think that the prime minister can and
will
return to a course of renewal and
democratization
or might we now be seeing the beginning
of a pattern that's all too familiar
where
a leader comes into office with big
promises and big aims
and then gradually moves down toward the
road toward dictatorship
to be honest with you it would be a
great disappointment for me
if this would happen but this is not
what i see
coming up for me the root of all
evil is the ethiopian constitution
a constitution which calls itself which
calls ethiopia
an ethnic federation ethnic federation
that means ethiopia is the only state
in the whole world with a system like
that
there is no other country in this world
with an ethnic
federation and that is what ruined us
ethiopia became
the most racist country in the world
we're the only place in africa where in
our
in our uh identity cards you have the
word
race written on it all our politics
until two years ago was based upon
ethnicity
the parties where ethnic parties are
borders with ethnic
and you know we have seen in the world
where you have ethnic borders
ethnic cleansing is not very far away
and in order to say no to this
but yes to federalism i'm a great
federalist
myself what ethiopia needs
is a democratic federal system
where all 120 ethnic groups
feel a part of one big
country and still believe they
are the masters of their fate meanwhile
and unfortunately we're just about out
of time uh mikhan and messena but
you did say you think the conflict will
continue so i really must ask
about the effects on the region as a
whole forty thousand uh
refugees already uh in the vulnerable
country of sudan uh
somalia also right next door equally
vulnerable
ethiopia used to be viewed as an anchor
of stability in africa
is that over i
do not think it's over but probably
the detention is so big that it may also
include eritrea because eritrea is
directly
member of tigray and sudan may be
involved in the one or the other way so
i i think
we are on the verge of this disability
if we don't manage to quickly come to a
table
and then negotiate the differences so i
think
militarily cannot be solved what we can
do and what should be done is
on the table thank you very much thanks
to all of you for being with us here
today and thanks to all of you for
tuning in see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
you